Speaker 1: With Trump's arrest looming, he is
now begging for money. Begging for money first
and foremost, Trump also dumping in the
George Soros stuff. Let me mention that.
Speaker 3: George Soros, the Club for No Growth
and other globalist special interests, including
the Koch family, will spend billions and billions
of dollars against us, and they don't have our
interests at heart. They want a president that can
be controlled like a puppet. And that's exactly.
Speaker 1: Guys, it's it's all the
words, right? Soros puppet globalist.
Speaker 3: Actually what they get
with somebody like Joe Biden. Instead,
our movement is funded by patriots like you
who are fighting to take our country back.
Speaker 1: So the context here is we
need money to fight against Soros and
the indictment. The whole thing to.
Speaker 3: Make America great again.
Nothing terrifies Soros more than seeing
millions and millions of hardworking
Americans donating five, 20, even $47.
Speaker 1: There you go. When George Soros,
at age 92, plots against Trump by getting him
arrested and he sees Joe Blow donating $47,
Soros is just quaking in his boots. Look
at the imaginary fantasy world he has to
create in order to get people to donate money.
Speaker 3: To save our country from Democrats
destruction. You see what they're doing
to our cities. They're being destroyed.
Together, we will make America great again.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Yeah. Make America great
again. Trump then posting, also continuing
to ask for money on truth social quote. If
you're doing poorly as so many of you are,
don't send anything if you're doing well,
which was made possible through the great
policies of the Trump administration. Send
your contribution to Donald J. Trump dot
com. We have to take back our capital C
country and all caps make America great again.
That that's like a little extra thing in there.
If you're not doing well today, it's because
of Joe Biden. If you are doing well today,
it's because of my policies from years ago.
But send Trump the money if you're doing well
for whatever reason. Send Trump the money begging
for cash as his arrest looms. Can he even possibly
raise enough money for the number of criminal
cases that there could Critical word could be
coming up against him? We will see and we
will see if indeed he gets arrested tomorrow.